how's it going bros my name is Berta and
today I'm here with the most amazing
most beautiful most fantastic girl in
the world
yes I'm just gonna say it no um so today
we have these muscle relaxants I'm gonna
put them on me where should I put them
eh my cheeks are you serious I don't
think that's a good idea
oh god it's already on why did you say
that after I put it on it's no I'm not
taking it off now it's sticky I've heard
the one person where should I put it
roll em seriously okay I promise it's
okay so do we know our partner partner
okay first question what's my best
friend's okay you can say - I don't know
who you put yeah okay favorite music
group do you have anything you read no
you know exactly yeah okay alright I
don't know okay you make it into famous
okay Cooper's name one of my hobbies I'm
so ready okay why don't you hobbies
Yemeni okay I don't know which one I
prefer Bubb you Jimmy
you're right
fashion come on are you doing stop suey
yeah yeah yeah what is it myself okay
how many years well next year it'll be
five years okay what's your favorite way
to spend an evening oh my oh you're
you're spending evening playing Isaac
your favorite ready to spend on your
name watching move bunch of horror film
ah how is that not correct
what kind of books timeless like to read
I'll shut myself for that once you like
banana Mishimoto
which side of the bag do I prefer the
one away from the windows yeah that is
not there you don't care about your
bedside no I care Eliza's I'm nice to
give you the best one yeah what is one
of my favorite desserts creme brulee oh
dude calm down
Jesus Christ how much did you expect
your favorite dessert is Tammy sue you
scream like you pain out of like you
telling ice creamy white chocolate with
chocolate inside it was such a teller
that's it what foods do I hate which we
do I hate
fish yeah favorite ways to relax
yes take a bath and wash that flavor
okay stop
I don't know sue can you cover the party
night yes get your glass of water
massage yes of course okay well this has
been eye-opening I'm taking these out
okay Sammis ballasted for the video
thank you for watching uh I'll see you
in the next don't discuss the camera
breakfast breakfast so you do different
things
oh you got a frisbee cool oh I'll be on
the bridge